[Music]
foreign
jonathan hey what
what is this where are you well right
now i'm in the
um it's called i think the south
deck well i can show you here
you see this is this is what i'm uh
looking at
you can actually see what i'm seeing
this is my view
can you see yeah hold on so are you in
tel aviv now wearing a
headset oh yeah right now i'm in
virtual reality i'm in uh mexi tel aviv
it's peter
but don't tell anyone okay tel
and while i'm in virtual reality
um i deal a lot in vr and ar and
i like natural interfaces and right now
yeah we're doing this conference from
this is like an
environment um for sharing for
uh watching videos shows with your
friends and
i can stream how big
am i on your screen right now or in your
eyes
technically uh you can be huge i can
show you a bit
um if you want to see okay so right now
you see what i'm looking at is a small
screen and you
see it like yeah yourself back and again
but i can add the big screen
and wait and then
if i go back and then
what what's how are you pointing do you
have some things on your fingers
well yeah i have two controllers in my
hands
so technically you could see
do you see what i'm looking at now yeah
in a second
my i just needed to open the door
yeah we have a new puppy in town so
sometimes he needs to go with me
yeah so i'm saying what you're saying so
uh basically i
i'm seeing my computer screen on a large
screen
so that's interesting filling up your
whole head right now
yeah right now i'm i'm seeing the whole
thing around me if you you see what i'm
seeing
yeah yeah so yeah that right now i'm
looking at these
over the balcony and now i'm looking
back at the screen
and i can now bring up a menu so now i'm
only saying the email i'm only saying
your browser
yeah right now it's the browser and
we don't need the big screen and i wanna
wait i do need the big screen to put
this back on there you go
and then i'll go be going back to my
stream cams which i've set up
in advance oh so cool
so and that's it okay all right so
virtual reality augmented reality
how did you get into this all right
how did you get into this and yeah this
is uh
this is a better representation of me
maybe yeah but in vr i can choose how i
look like
so yeah that's my hair for now how do i
get into it
well um actually i've been fascinated
with natural interfaces since i was
little
i was one of the first palm users and
back
when google glass came out i was one of
the first google glass explorers
and you know we thought the future is
really here already and we'd be walking
around with
augmented reality headsets uh
and i i actually left my job to you know
focus on that developing apps for
virtual reality
augmented reality and um we saw that
google glass wasn't working out that
well
and uh i was working on a platform for
um actually i wanted to create a
controller for google glass
back then the the interface was uh
it was very limited it was a tap
interface you could tap on your site or
talk to it
and that's very nice for a lot of things
but now when you go around in public
right it's embarrassing a lot of times
or you want some
different interface some confidentiality
and so i started working on a ring
and we made that out to be uh it was a
startup that we founded the
controller for smart things wearables
and then we started creating a lot of
controllers for virtual reality
why do you like virtual reality so much
what is it about you what is it about
virtual reality that
makes you go crazy well uh
vr is is very nice for instance
i can you know uh i can do a lot of
stuff in vr
very easily uh from the comfort of my
home
you know right now so we switched an
environment and you can see uh
i'm not sure what you're seeing right
now i'm seeing a couch with the
beautiful landscape of a city
yeah i can go back to another
camera and maybe here you see so now i'm
looking at this um in this living room
and you can actually in vr you can do a
lot of things
um from learning to
playing to um you know
even useful tools here i could just use
some
uh instead of some nice tricks like
and of course do you see the popcorn
yeah oh my god yeah i can play with a
lot of things but we can also
make it something useful i could use
some
some of these um paints
to illustrate maybe uh some point that
we're talking about
a little to you yeah just sick
yeah these environments are still not
you know optimized for it
wow this is so cool it's just
getting there so wait this camera is in
my back right
it's like oh yeah right wait here
here wait yeah better
here okay so now you see if i wanna
that's i wanna illustrate something
so you know i can be very creative with
it
oh that is so awesome and you know
yeah and that's just you know me being
uh
not very creative i bet other people
could do much better
but it's uh actually what i'm really
fascinated about is
augmented reality vr is is a great thing
it's
it's mainly for me entertainment
and uh you know some productivity
um but it's basically entertainment
right now
um what i'm really excited about is
augmented reality you know walking
around with um
with glasses that basically uh
put another layer on on reality you know
i can see
i can choose how the environment will
look like i mean i could choose to see
the whole world
pink or in 8-bit if i choose
you know that that's a dream or play
games you know gather around with
friends
each holding a sword gun or whatever and
fight a magical dragon in the park oh my
god so that
that's what i'd like to do with my spare
time
um developing things like that and of
course playing and enjoying it
all kinds of games like that but it's
still going on the headsets are still in
development
so that's why i started developing we
started out with controllers
back in gemsense and then i spent a year
developing an augmented reality headset
for skiing
ride on when we talked about it back
then um
and you know it's basically a augmented
reality display
inside a helmet for use while
skiing real world skiing and
it's a lot of fun and it's growing
um the problem is that these devices are
very hard to make and the
huge investments in the field haven't
really shown any
uh returns on big returns on investment
and nobody knows when they're expected
to show
so that's a big problem in the area so
it's developing real slowly
and in the meanwhile you know um
creating uh
fun apps fun activities with the devices
you know enabling more
learning why why are my eyes shut i
don't know
enabling more learning and developing
with uh
you know new technology is basically
what i'm uh
fascinated about so you're not just i
mean you're not just
having fun you're you're an expert on on
virtual reality and augmented reality
and you you worked with well i am as
well so tell me tell me a little bit
about what you did with him
and and how does it fit into this whole
story of your passion
well um well i am is is
he's a passion you know by himself he's
in
you know he's an amazing man and like uh
i'm a fan since i was younger yeah um
basically we started out they made a vr
experience
and we kind of hooked up on that um
and then they wanted to create their own
augmented reality
experience and have that uh
like a themed house or a small park
with their brand and uh so that's how we
uh collaborated and i actually took him
on a tour to see some companies here in
israel
who do some cool stuff in vr and ar
things that we wanted to cooperate on
uh we almost did a big project here we
had a lot of
um scouting activities on companies
technology that they're looking for
we hadn't haven't had any real big
success yet
um we did some small projects but
nothing i can really show yet
wow that's very very cool so i'd love to
talk a little bit i showed him some kung
fu
i taught the man some kung fu why am i
not surprised
um i wanna i wanna hear your your take
on what's happening now with corona
and with um and and how
virtual reality and augmented reality
might play into this and you know i'm
i'm here actually
most of my family is in israel and in
quarantine and i'm here
and near los angeles also in quarantine
and
you know it could be weeks or months
before we get to
to really see feel and and interact face
to face
and while we do a daily video chat with
you which is nice it's still very
limited
so obviously virtual reality and
augmented reality may be of help here
how far are we from having it become
more of a norm and
how can it improve our experience in
times like this
well it's uh it's improving a lot i have
to say
um vr is really ripe today you can
actually buy uh it's at the console
state right now you can buy for four
or five hundred dollars you can get a
standalone headset that doesn't need a
strong computer
and you can start doing um things like
these
uh you can play games you can do
training sessions you can do video
conferencing with people
um you can get a really a lot of
value out of a device like that yeah so
for experts who already have the devices
conferences in vr have started already
there have been small conferences and
now they did a big one
htc uh did their annual uh vive
conference
uh in vr because uh yeah
it wasn't too much it was a few hundred
participants i think
um i actually missed it because they had
to uh
pre-register for it you know bandwidth
limitations and stuff these days
um but it's it happened it looks good
you can see the video
i can share the link later and um
it works it's just uh when everybody has
the equipment it's very nice
and i'm actually working on another uh
vr
party i want to host a big vr party
but you do need the device to to join
so that's a bit of a limitation right
now
but it's really going down we've seen vr
pretty much going mainstream this year
um
there are about 100 titles that made
over a million dollars already
in the vr stores really there are
devices out there
that anyone can grab for 400 or 500
that are top-notch so today it's
going more mainstream but don't expect
your mother and father to grab them
tomorrow you know yeah um i mean
for work it's it's going there because
big companies have shown a lot of value
from developing products using virtual
reality
for example bell showed that's a great
use case that i'd like to talk about
they showed how they developed a
helicopter which usually takes them like
uh six or seven years to develop they
did it in six
months that's saving years of
development
and i don't know how many hundred of
millions of dollars
instead of fabricating parts every time
like this
i don't know propeller or wing or or
even the cockpit itself they created it
in a virtual reality
basically you know let's say
if i want to try to be creative yeah so
we draw we draw the cockpit
and then we see if i fit in there you
know you can draw it
yeah don't worry it's virtual it's back
here
okay so you see you can draw all the
lines this is hilarious
yeah technically you can draw all the
lines see how it fits
see if i can push the buttons uh you
know engineers can look at it
if i ditch this
i can usually grab
oh it's whoa it's 3d yeah it's a 3d
creation so you can
look around it whoa walk inside it
you can really uh feel it you know i'm
i'm misrepresenting here you can
actually
feel uh the space and then
and then people um multiple teams can
see feel the uh object or the
environment without even
having to uh come together or fabricate
any parts that's that's just incredible
wow so do you think this will become
a norm at some point for us to
communicate
even like we're communicating now just
talking as friends
yeah unfortunately these corona times
yeah this is this is going to become
much more of a norm
uh no but i mean a lot of things in
terms of virtual reality and augmented
reality
will we be using those tools rather than
just regular video call using our
computer or camera
so augmented reality is really
pretty much hard to tell because we've
been expecting
facebook and apple to take out glasses
this year
and really push it forward augmented
reality people walking around with
glasses outside that would show more
data from their phone
um maybe have cameras so they can maybe
recognize
people or show us things you know mark
things
and you know highlight things in the
virtual with virtual objects
um but that um that might take a while
due to the
corona also and walking around on side
which will not happen too much the
the next year hopefully less
but in in retrospect vr
is staying at home alone with your own
headset
that's a use case it's going to grow a
lot so for all kinds of communications
training hr purposes maybe
i don't know that's probably going to
grow a lot uh
a lot soon how often do you have a
headset on versus
not having a headset when you're working
in your house
uh that's a good question about half the
time i'm with a headset
uh if i develop if i'm developing for vr
it's even more than that but half the
time
uh i put on a headset this one or
another if i'm
working on a on a project yeah it's
better headsets for developers actually
have a tilt up
where you can just tilt up the uh
the goggles themselves and you know keep
working because it's not
uh that comfortable to be in vr for too
long
yeah okay the the headsets are still not
the
most comfortable thing yeah i can stay
with it for hours
but when you take it off when you you
feel the difference
yeah and for regular people it's even
harder
so there isn't there's still limits to
be solved the devices will be smaller
the
methods will be easier today we're using
this
but there are tools that are being built
specifically for these purposes
facebook had their own thing facebook
spaces
it was much better tool than this and i
could do some more things
for um conferencing with a few people
and uh but that's down now because
they're working on their new
product horizon which is not out yet so
we're gonna see a lot of vr happening in
next few years
ar i'm not so sure it might be delayed
even more
should have happened maybe you know
started happen this year but
it will probably be delayed a bit more
because holding up your phone you know
to do
augmented reality applications is nice
it has a novelty but it runs
it runs by real quickly you know it's
not that interesting after a while
but if you get it in your glasses you
know you walk around and you see hey
this is michael and this is the last
thing you you said to him and this is
what you wrote down you want to say to
him a dream stuff like that that would
be fun
a dream jonathan before uh before we
finish
i need three words that describe you
uh i'm virtualjohny.com
i'm virtualjohny.com fantastic thank you
so so much this was fascinating
thank you a lot of fun thank you for
having me here
great